bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france quels sont vos
informations concernant la libération du
président déchu ibrahim boubacar keïta
j'ai un bon jour en fait l'information
que nous avons reçue c'est de dire que
hier soir vers 3 heures du matin le pdk
a été transféré à son domicile des
micros pour vous c'est une mesure pour
renforcer un peu la confiance entre
l'agencé a pris le pouvoir et la
communauté internationale pour montrer
que ils sont pas là pour un règlement de
comptes
donc pour le moment c'est la seule
information qui a circulé peut-être de
la journée on aura d'autres formations
de détails sur comment il a été même qui
l'a ramené chez lui
et s'agissant de son entourage proche sa
famille dont son fils karim keita mais
aussi
les ministres et les anciens ministres
les anciens membres du gouvernement
malien
alors pour le voir son fils karim
keita et des personnes arrêtées il ya
beaucoup l'hypothèse selon laquelle il
serait réfugié à l'ambassade de la côte
d'ivoire à bobo mais pour le reste le
premier ministre dr boost et et le
lancement de l'assemblée nationale
estime bini n'ont pas été libérés pour
le moment ils sont six jours à cassis
dans une résidence placée sous le
contrôle des militaires
je pense que la cédéao ci va contrer les
discussions avec la junte au pouvoir
c'est une sorte de monnaie d'échangé
hostile que vous savez que l'embargo
n'est pas toujours rêver donc libéré le
plaisir car c'est déjà une place des
mesures de confiance de façon de montrer
que ce sont de bonne foi mais s'il
venait à libérer la population qui
attend ça sent quand même deux des
actions par exemple je suis leur
stabilité notamment les massacres des
distances de douzy jouets sont en effet
vous pouvez rester assez mis en place
donc espèce de façon aussi un peu de
mettre la pression sur ce site et dans
le sort réservé à l'ancien président
bush ibrahim boubacar keïta l'exil
peut-être ou alors il va il pourrait
être jugé dans son pays répondre des
accusations d'être justement on l'accuse
d'être responsable de la crise
sécuritaire politique et économique du
pays alors officiellement il n'y a pas
de mon point de vue c'est rare que les
rsp chez lui comme il fait assez souvent
des visites médicales en asie et enfin
il sera autorisé d'après l'agent a plus
de pouvoir à se rendre là où il faudra
pour ses soins médicaux donc je ne suis
pas sûr que les pzk widemann et de
l'exil
parce que bon il n'y a pas de quoi en
fait parce que c'est tellement ne lui
reproche rien
et si on venait à lui reprocher quelque
chose ce serait plus indiqué de se
mettre à la disposition du juge pour une
écoute et éventuellement voir qu'est ce
que l'art histoire donc pour moi c'est
pas il n'est pas forcément ici parce que
les maliens ne vont pas aller chez lui
sa taille et son domicile
si vous voulez les faire leur effet
depuis le ministre lors des vols point
de vue il ne craint pas pour sa vie
mais les autorités compétentes et là
aussi à ce niveau là il n'a pas froid
quelque chose à quoi est ce que c'est
cette première libération va pouvoir
accélérer la le processus de transition
que promet la junte militaire au pouvoir
il ya des discussions qui sont entamées
avec le mouvement du 5 juin notamment
d'avoir comme je les dis c'est
libération qui vient à point nommé parce
que ça permet entre à la fédéraux
d'avoir plus confiance à la junte et à
ses 10 rebonds ses partenaires avec
lesquels on peut travailler parce que
les négociations qui vont se faire entre
maliens pour déterminer la nomenclature
de la transition ça dure et les organes
cover met en place tout ça peut se faire
sous l'égide de la cedeao donc la junte
avait récusé les cdo de libérer les
paysans et des cas ça pourrait
cristalliser un peu les tensions et à
pouvaient conduire la cdoa maintenir son
embargo
l'appartement le président a libéré
devant la télé ou peu cher aux siens en
allégeant très mal la barbe ou bien
simplement en mettant fin à l'embargo
et de l'autre côté le malien a construit
les discussions parce que la classe
politique est reçu par la junte
là c'est steve hill les syndicats donc
je viens c'est un ballet
le visiteur à kati et souvent aussi au
niveau de la sphère de la défense donc
pour moi ça va attirer les processus et
dès le début de la semaine prochaine
on peut voir d'autres maliens
merci à vous brahma et les dicos je
rappelle que vous êtes enseignant
chercheur à l'université des lettres et
sciences humaines de bamako fin